in our modern culture when we want to
overcome embarrassment we we just try to
push through it we say you shouldn't if
you feel shame you should just tell
yourself not to feel shame don't allow
anybody to shame you or no shame it can
be a very good thing it's a good feeling
because it tells us maybe we've done
something wrong maybe we're on the wrong
path we should embrace that shame and
then
turn things around and go in the other
direction be like it'd be like turning
off all your nerve endings you say oh I
feel so much better now yeah maybe but
when you put your hand on a hot stove
you're going to set your whole body on
fire you need those nerve endings you
need a little bit of that shame you need
to look at that and admit what we all
know is true which is
it's embarrassing